on this tuesday night ukraine's
president challenges the u.n
vladimir zelinski asks what's the point
of the u.n if it won't hold russia
accountable
are you ready to close the u.n if your
answer is no then you need to act
immediately more graphic evidence of
civilians killed in bucha and the
chilling russian plan to erase ukraine
as a country
pandemic protection the new guidance on
a second booster shot and the province's
extending mass mandates
climate goals can canada's energy sector
ramp up production while cutting
emissions plus an evolving story they
have potatoes the mysterious
disappearance and return of charles
darwin's manuscripts
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
ukraine's president gave some blistering
and blunt advice to the united nations
security council today in a virtual
address vladimir zelinski essentially
asked what is the point of the u.n what
security is it guaranteeing if it
doesn't act to stop vladimir putin
russia is a permanent member of the u.n
security council that gives it veto
power over decisions zolensky says
russia has turned that veto power into a
license to kill
you can do two things
either remove russia as an aggressor and
a source of war
so it cannot block decisions about its
own aggression its own war
or if there is no alternative and no
option
then the next option would be dissolve
yourself all together
the horror of what happened in bucha he
says is not the only atrocity he says
there are others the world has yet to
see he ended his briefing to the u.n
with an extremely graphic video showing
burned corpses and mass graves there is
no way to tell this story unless we show
some of those images or risk sanitizing
what's really happening our coverage
begins with crystal commencing ukraine
needs peace europe needs peace and the
world needs peace at the urging of
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
the u.n security council sat silently
confronted by video proof of the horrors
of russia's war on ukraine the images
are difficult to look at
some we have blurred for broadcast
bodies of ukrainian civilians dead in
the streets and mass graves they are
awful images of
war ukraine's leaders forcing the world
to face this grim reality and demanding
accountability from council members
against russia the massacre in our city
of butcher is only one unfortunately
only one of many examples of what the
occupiers have been doing on our land
for the past 41 days independent groups
are currently working to determine if
the atrocities constitute war crimes
such as confirmed strikes on 85 health
facilities and worker sites
investigations are also underway for the
use of cluster munitions as well as the
treatment of prisoners of war
zolensky has shared accounts of russian
soldiers raping looting and killing
indiscriminately
clearly frustrated he told the u.n
tuesday that if it can't ensure peace
and security its security council should
consider dissolving
one nation called on the council to
reassure the world of its relevance
russia's representative lashed out at
the notion the federation is violating
international law again claiming the
images from bucha are fake and accusing
ukrainian nationals of killing civilians
every lie we hear
from the russian representative is more
evidence that they do not belong on the
human rights council
the call by the u.s to suspend russia
from the human rights council comes as
nato anticipates more intense fighting
in the south and east of ukraine canada
2 says that russia should be suspended
from the u.n human rights council
foreign affairs minister melanie jolie
writing on social media russia's utter
disregard for human rights could not be
any clearer russia has no place on the
unhrc
donna all right crystal comancing in
london thank you
the brutality of what russia is doing in
ukraine is not random acts of violence
it is part of a plan vladimir putin has
said multiple times ukraine is not a
real country that it belongs to russia
this week a state-run news agency
published an op-ed spelling it out
further in justifying the war or special
operation as it's called in russia the
author claims ukrainianism is a greater
threat to the world than hitler's nazi
party and claims because a significant
part of the masses are passive nazis and
accomplices of nazism then russia's
punishment of civilians is justified it
also says ukraine's elite must be
eliminated as re-education is impossible
a reminder ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky is jewish and he's a descendant
of holocaust survivors
that theme of denatifying unfounded by
any facts is repeated in a letter
written by dimitri medvedev he's a
former president of russia
he also calls for the cultural genocide
of ukraine these complex tasks do not
happen all at once medieval rights and
they will be decided not only on the
battlefields he ends with this chilling
line the goal is for the sake of the
peace of future generations of
ukrainians and the opportunity to
finally build an open eurasia from
lisbon to vladivostok
at the same time the kremlin which
completely controls the media in russia
is ramping up denials any civilians have
been killed part of its propaganda
strategy to confuse deflect and hide the
truth redmond shannon on the evidence in
bucha and the response from the west and
another warning some of the images are
disturbing
with bodies now removed from the streets
of bucha video from ukraine's state
emergency service shows workers removing
unexploded shells
but authorities expect to discover many
more bodies in kiev's suburbs in the
coming days
i don't know exactly what happened to
that house says this man in a nearby
town but there are people under the
rubble there
russia claims the deaths in bucha were
staged after russian troops left at the
end of march despite the mounting
evidence these satellite images show
bodies on abuja street almost two weeks
earlier an analysis by the new york
times shows they were lying in the same
positions when the russian troops left
and this drone video appears to show the
moment a cyclist was gunned down the
video matching the same position where a
body and a bike were later found
british prime minister boris johnson
attempted to break through russia's
propaganda machine with his own
bilingual message condemning vladimir
putin he knows that these crimes betray
the trust of every russian mother the
horrors of bucha triggering what is now
a fifth round of sanctions from the
european union clearly in view of events
we need to increase our pressure further
we will impose an import ban on coal
from russia
worth 4 billion euros per year the eu
also sanctioning russian shipping plus
exports of wood seafood and liquor but
not russian oil or gas europe simply too
reliant on those imports for
now from the czech republic say its
government is now the first to send
tanks to ukraine we currently
are in need of heavy weapons like planes
tanks
armored personnel vehicles ukraine again
warning that russia's retreat from kiev
is only intended to redouble the force
of its invasion in the east redmond
shannon global news london
western humanitarian aid continues to be
turned away from the besieged city of
mariopol where tens of thousands of
residents are trapped this drone footage
shows long lineups today outside a
former shopping center it's believed
people are getting aid from russian
forces the red cross says its team
attempting to bring supplies in and get
people out was turned away after being
held by police near the port city the
aid agency says it's been working to
reach mariupol since last week without
success ukraine says thousands of
residents there have been forcibly
deported to russia
the war in ukraine has put canada's
military spending in the spotlight the
next federal budget will be delivered on
thursday with russia's aggression there
is pressure on all western countries to
hike defense spending and keep their
commitments to norad and nato abigail
beeman on what canadians can expect
bigger defense budget is needed now not
a new call but canada's lagging military
spending and outdated equipment is now
center stage in the wake of russia's
invasion of ukraine add in pressure from
allies to hit the 2 percent of gdp nato
defense spending target canada is
currently at 1.4 percent what is your
number
and pressure from successive u.s
administrations ottawa has been
signaling more spending is coming in
thursday's budget with norad
modernization on the table with
increased investments in defense the
arctic is an area we're going to look
closely at new democrats support some
investments but we do not believe that
the two percent that nato is
recommending is appropriate for canada
we don't think it would be achievable
while conservatives want liberals to
meet that target
and more action on the f-35 fighter jet
deal our defense is woefully
understaffed and underfunded and
under-equipped some analysts believe we
could see billions of dollars in
increased military spending thursday in
terms of what could be included
specifics on norad modernization is high
on the list it's definitely a weakness
certainly with climate change and sort
of opening up the arctic towards being
more accessible both by you know russia
to illustrate china in addition
post-afghanistan retirement stretched
staff helping in the pandemic and
climate change disasters plus military
misconduct scandals have meant a drain
on experienced staff with institutional
knowledge difficult to replace
all the stuff that's been going on for
the past year and a half that we've been
talking about that affects recruitment
and retention and while no one expects a
quick fix thursday there's also the
problem of a broken procurement system
incredibly cumbersome split between
three departments you know multiple
central agencies
process after process anytime there's a
problem they build more process throwing
billions of dollars at the military
won't do much if there's no effective
way to get projects completed quickly
another thing military watchers will be
watching for how much of the financial
commitments are up front and how much
will be years in the making abigail
beeman global news ottawa
we will have live coverage of the
federal budget this thursday starting at
four o'clock eastern on global tv and on
line at globalnews.ca
the federal government has introduced a
bill that would make big tech companies
like google and meta share their revenue
with canadian media outlets bill c-18
creates a process for online platforms
to negotiate privately with professional
media outlets the heritage minister says
canada's news sector is in crisis
there's a rise in fake news and tech
giants are profiting from news content
without having to pay to produce it
we want to make sure that news outlets
and journalists receive fair
compensation for their work
we want to make sure that local
independent news thrives
in our country
if the bill becomes law digital
platforms that don't comply with the new
rules could face fines of up to 15
million dollars
the sixth wave and a fourth dose coming
up the new guidance for a second booster
shot for canadians
it's been over two years since activity
in most canadian cities came to an
almost complete halt public health
restrictions kept many people at home
that's not a distant memory for people
in china there is a surge of kovid 19
cases there 23 cities are in total or
partial lockdown including shanghai mike
delay reports on china's zero kovid
strategy
shanghai considered the heart of china's
financial sector rarely stops beating
yet the streets are eerily quiet 26
million residents are stuck at home
waiting for updates from the robot dogs
now being used to share public health
information it's a very strict lockdown
in fact i've seen people calling it
one of the strictest lockdowns in the
world
we're not allowed to leave home at all
all public transport has been cancelled
you're not even allowed to leave the
front door
china has frequently implemented strict
lockdowns to control the spread of covet
19. there are currently 23 cities under
full or partial lockdown as china
continues to strive to completely
eradicate the virus an all-encompassing
strategy known as covet zero one new
zealand gave up on last fall
epidemiologists now argue vaccines and
mask mandates are more effective
i don't think at this point
in fact at any point
long-term lockdown is really the answer
to you know to to responding to kobe 19.
chinese officials however say they are
unwavering in their goal a small army of
health officials was brought in to test
nearly all shanghai residents and while
over 20 000 asymptomatic cases were
caught
symptomatic cases numbered under 700.
people i don't think are worried in
china and in shanghai about the covet
itself and they're more worried i think
about catching it because of the hassle
that it will cause because of course in
china anyone who tests positive needs to
go into central quarantine the strain of
the lockdown is starting to show with
the rise in social media complaints
putting into question how long the
current strategy is sustainable
microlight global news toronto
there is new guidance on covid19
vaccines in this country the national
advisory committee on immunization is
recommending the rapid deployment of
second booster shots for people aged 80
and over and for residents of long-term
care homes health authorities can also
consider giving the additional booster
for people between the ages of 70 and
79. the fourth shot should be given six
months after the previous dose until now
a fourth dose was only recommended for
immunocompromised people
we are going to be offering a spring
booster for elders and seniors in
british columbia as the people being
most at risk
bc is already set to roll out second
boosters for people 70 and older
indigenous people over the age of 55 and
those who are immunocompromised only
about half of the people in that
province have received their first
booster shot
and masks remain one of the most
effective ways to prevent virus
transmission many provinces though have
already lifted their mask mandates two
are now extending those mandates quebec
is extending its mass mandate for indoor
public spaces until the end of the month
as that province deals with an uptick in
new infections and hospitalizations and
masks will still be worn in pei until
april 28th though the provincial state
of emergency there will end at midnight
and capacity limits will be lifted
like oil and water ahead how canada's
climate goals clash with new global
energy demands
you're watching global national
[Music]
this week's report from the u.n
intergovernmental panel on climate
change was clear the world is running
out of time and options at the same time
russia's invasion of ukraine has
countries looking for other sources of
oil and gas that's prompted the canadian
government to challenge the energy
sector here can you ramp up production
and scale back greenhouse gas emissions
as heather urex west explains it's put
the industry and its investors in a
delicate spot
the world needs oil and canada has it
but when it comes to energy things are
never so simple it's certainly a time of
a lot of turbulence obviously you have
these very short-term
impacts with the war in
ukraine the wall street journal is
reporting the white house wants more
canadian oil coming into the u.s but
only by rail or existing pipelines
keystone xl remains off the table
because while the world needs more
energy it also needs global emissions
cut and fast we must work with industry
and provinces and we must cap and reduce
emissions from the oil and gas sector
the ipcc makes very clear that the oil
and gas sector cannot do business as
usual last week the federal government
announced a plan to curb canadian oil
and gas industry emissions by 42
by 2030 something alberta's premier
calls impossible explicit is a reduction
in oil and gas production which would
just shift energy production from canada
to places like putin's russia and the
opec dictatorships this policy is it's
nuts but the industry itself which has
already committed to achieving net zero
emissions by 2050 sees the writing on
the wall we need to work with our
federal government to ensure that we can
get
our missions to be in a place where
they're comfortable but at the same time
we need to meet our world
responsibilities which is to produce
responsibly produced energy and sell it
worldwide with a growth focus on
renewables and exporting more liquefied
natural gas things we could do is
replace asian coal european coal with
lng but that would increase our
emissions
but yet it would reduce global emissions
that's well recognized ultimately the
world will need to transition away from
fossil fuels our reliance right now
proving to be just too much of a threat
heather eurix west global news calgary
better late than never next the
extremely valuable notebooks
mysteriously returned to a library
[Music]
the complexity and diversity of life on
earth was not properly understood until
a man named charles darwin started
studying nature in great detail and
taking notes his trip nearly 200 years
ago to the galapagos islands helped
shape his theory of natural selection so
when two of his treasured notepads were
stolen more than 20 years ago it was
devastating now as eric sorenson reports
they've reappeared as mysteriously as
they vanished
they are the notebooks of charles darwin
invaluable irreplaceable housed at the
university of cambridge darwin's notes
were the starting point for the theory
of evolution these are the notebooks in
which that theory was put together
they're some of the most remarkable
documents in the whole history of
science but 20 years ago the notebooks
vanished from the shelves apparently
stolen there were no cameras in these
aisles then or now so when this gift bag
was dropped off last month there wrapped
in plastic darwin's notebooks with the
message librarian happy easter ex i was
shaking you can you can hear that in my
voice and i felt joyful the notes were
written in the 1830s when darwin sailed
to the galapagos from island to island
he saw differences in tortoises and
birds a biologist he developed a theory
of natural selection in which species
compete and gradually evolve years later
he published on the origin of the
species but newspapers mocked the notion
that the pedigree of man could be traced
to apes the religious community fought
it for decades in 1920s tennessee john
scopes was found guilty for teaching
evolution the basis for a later
hollywood film on page 10
of the origin of the species darwin's
statement i object to this your honor
but darwin's theory became the
foundation of modern thinking around
human development and evolution of
species his treasured notes including a
tree of life are among the world's
foremost scientific documents the theory
of natural selection
and evolution is probably the single
most important theory in the life and
earth environmental sciences it is a
mystery they're in good condition the
eroded copper clasps confirmed for
researchers the notebooks are indeed
darwin's originals they've clearly been
looked after with care wherever they
have been
and the important thing is that they
have ended up back here but who took
them who brought them back and why the
investigation it seems is still evolving
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is a bird's-eye view of saint
anthony newfoundland and labrador we'd
love to see your canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you